in Wartime life without power can seem
like nothing compared to the darkness of
occupation
Vitali sirtiac is just one of many
Herson residents now sharing details of
Russian interrogations and beatings with
Ukraine again controlling the city
efforts are underway to provide people
with food water and electricity but with
the Russian Onslaught against the energy
Network it won't happen quickly and
residents are being encouraged to leave
Ukraine's grid remains firmly in
Russia's crosshairs the suffering
ukrainians are experiencing is
increasing as the temperature drops
Alexander hiroshenko says without
electricity water treatment plants don't
work heating systems go cold and cities
are plunged Into Darkness nobody sits
with their hands in their pockets I was
talking to one of the directors and they
say we just finished another repair but
every strike means more work and every
repair requires new replacement parts
which are now scarce rolling blackouts
allowed the country to share available
energy but Russia is squeezing that
Supply
I think there's a tactic to take people
by exhaustion but people are tough he
says and they're prepared to wait for
victory even if it means sitting in the
dark
Crystal gemancing Global News London